economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela buenas
noches comenzamos con noticias positivas
por primera vez en 25 años una mujer va
a presidir la organización mundial del
comercio de ciencia trata de santiago
muy buenas noches mire el director o
quien venía haciendo el director general
de esta entidad el brasileño roberto
acevedo se retiró hace pocas semanas
para ocupar un cargo ejecutivo en
pepsico ya los miembros de la ume se
adelantaron la tarea para escoger a su
reemplazo tras descartar a tres de los
cinco candidatos en la recta final están
la ex ministra de finanzas de nigeria 2
y okonjo iweala
y la ministra de comercio de corea del
sur yu myung y lo interesante de esta
lección santiago es que se llevará a
cabo el 7 de noviembre justo cuatro días
después de los comicios presidenciales
en eeuu el candidato que gane será clave
en adelante para el organismo que ya ha
tenido varios tropiezos con donald trump
muy fluidos o coreanos daniela hablemos
ahora de eeuu porque allí reina la
incertidumbre sólo sobre uno
nuevos estímulos económicos si a
principios de esta semana se creía que
los representantes de los partidos
republicano y demócrata estaban
avanzando en una negociación sobre un
segundo paquete de ayudas pero el
presidente de donald trump se levantó el
martes de la mesa
al día siguiente revivió la esperanza
cuando el mandatario pidió un auxilio
económico para las aerolíneas y una
nueva ronda de pagos directos de 1200
dólares a los trabajadores pero la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi descartó la
aprobación de esa ayuda específica y
dejó esa inquietud en el aire sobre si
habrá o no más estímulos
yo he estado muy abierto a tener un
proyecto único independiente para las
aerolíneas como parte de un plan más más
grande pero no habrá una ayuda
independiente sino una más grande no
life is now de daniela los empresarios
del sector vitícola tanto de estados
unidos como la unión europea le dijeron
a washington y bruselas no peleen más ya
no más déjenos seguir trabajando así
después washington y bruselas recordemos
protagonizan hace casi dos décadas una
disputa comercial por cuenta de los
subsidios al gigante hervás que estados
unidos cree que afectaron a boing pues
uno de los damnificados de esa pelea por
estos días ha sido el sector nada más y
nada menos que de los vinos la casa
blanca impuso o subió también aranceles
para la importación de ciertos países
casi una veintena de organizaciones que
representan al comercio minorista la
restauración distribución y producción
de vino enviaron una carta a las
autoridades pidiendo que se limen esas
asperezas cuanto antes señalan que los
aranceles hoy son más perjudiciales que
nunca porque las restricciones por la
pandemia los tienen al borde de la
quiebra de los pasajeros sorprendido que
me tiene esta nota
a un tribunal de irlanda declaró que el
pan de los sándwiches de software no es
pan como así mire todo comenzó con una
disputa fiscal en irlanda los productos
catalogados como alimentos básicos no
están sujetos al impuesto al valor
agregado pues books finders es una
franquicia de sant boi en ese país y
dijo que sus sándwiches deberían estar
exentos de ese gravamen pero la corte
suprema rechazó este argumento el panel
de jueces determinó santiago que este
producto tiene tanta azúcar que
legalmente no puede ser considerado como
pan esto debido a que tiene un contenido
de azúcar del 10 por ciento del peso de
la harina incluida en la masa y que por
lo tanto supera el 2% especificado en la
categoría de alimento básico que no paga
impuestos el alto tribunal argumenta que
una cosa es el pan como alimento básico
santiago y otra muy diferente son los
productos de confitería horneados de
lujo póngale cuidado la respuesta de
huawei dice que llevan más de tres
décadas horneando pan que huele tan rico
como sabe no pues yo entiendo muchísimas
cosas
los indicadores como las faldas bolsas
hoy
la mayoría de bolsas del mundo mantiene
viva la esperanza de que habrá más
estímulos o street & tuvo ganancias
también en la subieron las bolsas
europeas como españa que tuvo un avance
de más del 1 por ciento y en américa
latina' la celebración fue aún mayor
brasil y méxico ganaron más del 2 por
ciento y las cifras vía para el cierre
2,4 euros graves esta cifra santiago en
países bajos una agencia financiada por
el gobierno calculó que eso se gasta al
día un empleado que trabaja desde su
casa en cosas como café papel higiénico
o servicios públicos algunas entidades
ya empezaron a aplicar esta
investigación para darles bonos extra a
sus colaboradores el teletrabajo muchas
gracias a daniela por esta información
es todo aquí en la economía en france 24
siga con nosotros
[Música]